tonight new video released of officers
shooting and killing a suspect happened
last week in the northwest valley
36-year-old stephen thomas was killed at
cheyenne and tenea on wednesday morning
joe muller joining us now live to tell
us why metro believes thomas wanted to
be shot by police joe
well before being shot and killed
outside of this apartment complex here
on tanea just north of cheyenne metro
says stephen thomas committed a number
of robberies in the area including
robbing a bank
this is body camera footage from
wednesday
it shows the tense moments that prompted
two metro officers to open fire despite
being struck by the vehicle you'll see
thomas
stands back up
and he points his firearm at sergeant
graham's 36-year-old steven thomas could
be seen pointing a gun and not
responding to commands thomas attempted
to get up with his gun several times and
officer lucac fired until he stopped
moving this shooting ended up being just
one part of the investigation metro says
thomas committed a number of crimes that
day including a carjacking attempting to
rob a convenience store and robbing a
credit union where he got away with cash
police followed thomas and that stolen
suv to cheyenne and tanea where the
shooting happened
police say this may have been something
he wanted the entire time during the
course of the investigation detectives
learned that on the day of the officer
involved shooting thomas grabbed a gun
and told his girlfriend
he was going to do something to get the
police
to shoot him
now back out here live during that press
conference earlier today metro did say
that thomas did have a criminal
background our i-team did also learn
that thomas was arrested in connection
with setting a fire inside a gas station
in summerlin last may reporting live joe
muller live local now